اعلنت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحزمه
جديده من العقوبه تستهدف مسؤولين كبارا
فالاستخبارات الايرانيه ومؤسسات تابعه
للحرس الثوري وتثير العقوبات التي
تتزامروا مع اخرى مشابهه فرضها الاتحاد
الاوروبي الاسئله بشان مصيري مساعي احياء
الاتفاق النووي بركه ان الطيران وان ندرد
بالعقوبات اكدت ان الرسائل بشان احياء
الاتفاق النووي لم تتوقف
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مساره ما حقيقه وجودي مساءا
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي الايرانيه في ضوء
رسائل متناقضه من الجانبين فهران تؤكل
التبادل الرسائل واشنطن تن في مساعيه
احياء الاتفاق وتقول انها لم تعد مطروحه
على لجنه الامريكيه
وفي اي سياق نقرا حزمه العقوبات الامريكيه
الاوروبيه الجديده على طيران التي طالت
قيادات ومؤسسات في الحرس الثوري وما واجهه
ربطها بمسار احياء مفاوضات النووي او
تجميدها
وكيف تتاثر دول المنطقه باستمرار حاله
الغموض والتوتر في العلاقات الامريكيه
الايرانيه وفي سياق تهديدات الاسرائيليه
المستمره للطيران ومشروعيه النوم
[موسيقى]
يه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي الايراني السوى
ان يرى في العقوبات الامريكيه الاوروبيه
رسائل تضع واقعه ومصير هذه الجهود تحت
الضوء من جديد عقوبات جعلت من طاعات
السلطات الايرانيه مع الاحتجاجات خلفيه
لها الا ان ذلك بدا غير بعيد ايضا عن
الملف النووي الذي يعاني الجمود منذ
سبتمبر الماضي رغم ان طهران ندرت
بالعقوبات ولوحت في رد مماثل عليها في وقت
قريب فانها في الوقت نفسه بدت حريصه على
عدم اغلاق الباب امام المسار الدبلوماسيه
المتعلقه بالملف النووي
وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه قالت ان ايران
تتطلع الى مفاوضات المتعدده الاطراف تقوم
على العقلانيه والواقعيه وتكون بعيدا عن
ما وصفاته بالضجيج الخارجيه الايرانيه
اضافت ان متابعه المفاوضات النوويه قضيه
مهمه وجده بالنسبه لنا واكر الطيران ان
التبادل الرسائل بشان ملف الاتفاق النووي
مستمر عبر قنوات دبلوماسيه واشار تيران
الى ان الاطراف الاخرى المعنيه بالمفاوضات
النوويه اظهرت اهتماما بالحفاظ على خطه
العمل الشامله المشتركه وقالت الخارجيه
الايرانيه ان ايران ستكون حاضره في اي
مفاوضات تضمن مصالحها الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
وائل مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الكويت
الدكتور عبد الله الشيخ استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه الكويت ومن الدوحه
دكتوره فاطمه الباحثه الاولى في مركز
الجزيره للدراسات ونريد ان نفهم معك دكتور
عبد الله اولا اي المؤشرات نعتمد هل نعتمد
ما يصدر من الجانب الغربي
الاتفاق النووي الايراني لم يعد على
الاجنده ولم يعد مطروحا على الطاوله الان
هذا حتى ذكره الاعلام الاسرائيلي ونقلا عن
الرئيس الامريكي الذي نقله في سبتمبر
الماضي لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي السابق
ام نعتمد الاشارات الايجابيه من طهاره
التي اعتبرتها الجاديا مازقا للدول
الغربيه هذه الاشارات الايجابيه بشهاده
برنامج الايراني
يعني لا شك ان
المفاوضات متعثره منذ مارس الماضي لا يزال
هناك غموض واضح حول هل تكون 20 23 التي
رحلت اليها ازمات 20 20
سنه الانفراج لكثير من الملفات بما فيها
ملف ايران النووي ولكن هناك الكثير من
الصعوبات في اعتقادي لا تزال قائمه ابرزها
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تلمح او او
ترسل رسائل متناقضه يعني هناك ليست من
الاجنده ليست من الاولويات ليست من ضمن ما
يمكن للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تضعه
في سلم اولوياتها ولكن في نفس الوقت هناك
تسريبات للقاء روبرتملي المبعوث الامريكي
همم الى ايران او يمسك بالملف النووي
الايراني مع السفير الامريكي في الامم
المتحده هناك تقارب مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهناك البرلمان الاوروبي يريد يصنف الحرس
الثوري منظمه ارهابيه فنره هناك التباس
هناك تراجع هناك اوراق ضغط على ايران
واضحه هناك ايضا تصعيد خطير من قبل
نتنياهو للمره السادسه يتقدم في حكومته
ويعني يصعد بشكل خطير ملمحا الى القيام
بعمل عسكري ويريد من واشنطن ان تزوده
بالاسلحه يعني هناك حرب نفسيه حرب اعلام
حرب يعني بالوكاله اذا صح التعبير ولكن لا
يبدو ان هناك ايضا في الكونجرس الامريكي
يوجد توجهين توجه لدعم اسرائيل في عمل
العسكري او تشدد مع ايران وفي نفس الوقت
الجناح الديمقراطي
همم اليسار
يرى بان اسرائيل تجر امريكا الى مواجهه
وهناك ايضا موقف دول الخليج يمكن اتكلم
عنها
لكن دكتور دكتور فاطمه ايضا ال- ال-
الاشارات القادمه من طهران همم ايضا احتاج
الى بعض التامل يعني اشارات بالرد على كل
ما يقال عن عقوبات اوروبيه او امريكيه
يعني تعهد مباشر وفوري بالرد على مثل هذه
العقوبات لكن ايضا حديث عن قنوات متعدده
لاعاده احياء الاتفاق النووي كيف نفهم
ايضا هذه الرسائل المختلفه من طهران
بالنسبه لايران ليست مساله العقوبات ليست
جديده هي اختبر الدورات متتاليه من
العقوبات ايضا همم ان تكون هذه العقوبه
تستهدف
الحرس الثوري ايضا هذه ليست همم مساله
جديده لكن المساله الجديده هي السائل
لتصنيف الحرس الثوري كمنظمه همم ارهابيه
هذا تحرك جديد تتعامل معه ايران بجديه همم
كبيره همم جدا لكن بالنسبه
للرسائل والرسائل المتناقضه همم كنت حدث
مع همم اناس مطلعين على همم موضوع
المفاوضات بشكل قريب جدا واكد ولي انه حتى
الايام القليله الماضيه كانت ايران تتلقى
رسائل بهذا الخصوص سواء من اطراف اوروبيه
او همم تنقل رسائل امريكيه
بموضوع الاستئناف المفاوضات وما الى ذلك
همم الضغوطات على ايران من خلال العقوبات
او همم من خلال التحديث بتصنيف همم الحرس
الثوري في ظني انها محاوله امريكيه
اوروبيه لدافع ايران مجددا الى طاوله
المفاوضات ليس للتفاوض ولكن للقبول بما هو
مطروح او مقدم من مشروع لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي وهو المقترح الذي سبقه عن رفضته
ايران لانها لم تجد فيه همم ما يجعلها
تتنازل عن التطور الذي حدث في البرنامج
النووي الايراني خاصه على في مسار
باليورانيوم عندما تتحدث الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان موضوع الاتفاق النووي ليس
مطروحا على الاجنده لكنها في الوقت ذاته
تؤكد انها ستقف ضد التطور الحاصل في
البرنامج النووي الايراني اذا ما كان
سيؤدي الى الوصول الى السلاح النووي لذلك
هناك عندما يسقط هذا البديل البديل احياء
الاتفاق النووي فنحن نتحدث عندما يسقط هذا
الخيار فا نحن نتحدث عن بديل والبديل
بالتاكيد لن يكون ساره همم للمنطقه همم
البديل يعني العامل الاسرائيلي سيدخل همم
ضمن المعادله العمل العسكري التوجيه ضربه
لايران وما الى ذلك وهذه كلها تعقد همم
القضيه في هذه الايام
وهنا اسال الدكتور عبد الله عما يفهمه
ايضا من التصريح الامريكي والتصريح الغربي
بان
الاتفاق النووي واعاده احيائه لم يعود لم
يعد على الاجنده لم يعد في جدول الاعمال
ويتزمن ذلك مع مناورات بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل هي الاكبر بين الجانبين
هل فعلا
اداره بادن ولا اتحدث عن الكونجرس اداره
بادن همم حسمت امرها فيما يتعلق بعدم
العوده الى المفاوضات بالشروط الايرانيه
المعروفه
لا طبعا هناك ضغوط على اداره بايدين من
الحلفاء الاوروبيين خاصه مجموعه
3 زائد يعني
الدول الاوروبيه الثلاثه اللي هي بريطانيا
او فرنسا والمانيا وكذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي
الذي يرى بان يعني هناك فرصه لان يكون
هناك اختراق مع ايران ما يجري هو مناورات
سياسيه في اعتقاده لممارسه اكبر ضغط على
ايران من اجل ان تفكر بشكل جدي وفرج ماتي
وعملي
بالاتفاق النووي يعني ايران عقدت الامور
بشيئين
بالرد القاسي وقت المئات المتظاهرين منذ
سبتمبر الماضي حتى الان تجاوز 500 الى 600
متظاهر
همم العقده الثانيه كانت بشكل واضح بتزويد
روسيا بسيارات شاهد والتي تلحق ضرار كبير
هنا التحتيه في اوكرانيا يعني هدينا
هاملين ساهم اكثر بموقف اكثر تشددا ولكن
لا يمكن ان نصدق بان اداره بايدن يعني في
شيء نسميه بالسياسه بلافينج الخداع
المتعمد للحصول على مكاسب اكثر وهذا هي
خطه اداره بايجن انه يريد ان يصعده ثم
يجتمع مالي مع السفير المندوب الايراني في
الامم المتحده ثم الى الاوروبيين يتكلمون
عن تصنيف الحراسه الثوري الايراني منظمه
ارهابيه ولكن الواقع ان الجميع يريد ان
يصل الى اتفاق نووي لان ايران همم اتقنت
نو هاو كيف تصنع القنبله النوويه هذه
المفروض منه الطريقه الوحيده لمنع ايران
من ان تصبح دوله نوويه في عهد اللي هو عند
نفس عقده اوباما الذي لا يريد في عهده ان
يسجل التاريخ في سجل الرؤساء بان في عهد
ايضا صارت ايران دوله نوويه وهو التوصل
الى اتفاق نووي يوم يمنع ايران من ان تصبح
دوله نوويه خلال السنوات القادمه وايضا
يثبت مصاعي نتن ياهو الذي هو اضعف رئيس
وزراء الان بحكومه هشه بحكومه من
المتطرفين العتات اليمين الفاشى الصهيوني
الذين يجعلون يعني بكل التطرف نتنياهو
يجعلونه بجناح الحمائم بينما في جناح
الصقور فهذه في في العديد من العوامل
تتفاعل معا ونرى يعني انعكاساتها خلال
الفتره القادمه على ذكر نتنياه همم نذكر
بما قاله ايضا همم الدول المعنيه في
الواقع عن قرب بتطورات الملف النووي تبقى
اسرائيل طبعا هي ابرز هذه الاطراف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ثاني ياهو تحدث عن فهو
مباحثاته مع مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيك سلف الاسبوع الماضي مشيرا الى ان
الملف الايراني
يوم خمسه
الماضي
زياره جاءت في وقت خاص فهناك تحديات جديه
تواجه امننا القومي
مع جيراننا تصدرت محادثاتنا التحديات
الامنيه والاقليميه وعلى راسها ايران
وايضا العمل وسبل التعاون بيننا عالم
مواجهه هذا التحدي المشترك علي ان اقول
انه في ختام لقاءاتنا كان لديهم طباعون
بان هناك رغبه متبادله وحقيقيه للتواصل
الى تفاهمات بشان هذه القضيه التي لها
اهميه
بالنسبه لامن دولتنا هذه المباحثات وستمر
خلال الاسابيع المقبله بيننا وبيننا
واشنطن
عادي لاضيوف يعود اليك يا دكتوره فاطمه
مساله وضع الحرس الثوري الايراني ضمن
المنظمات الارهابيه اوضح جثب بورن مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي انه
غير ممكن بدون حكم محكمه
مساله وضع على قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
يعني مساله ستستغرق وقتا طويلا حتى يصدر
حكم قضائي ولكل دوله ان تصدر حكما قضائيه
حتى يتم اتخذ ذلك في كل دوله لكن ما ماذا
عن العقوبات التي اعلن عنها الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقال الولايات المتحده على من
تؤثر تحديدا فيها
الدراسات التي اجريت سواء داخل ايران او
خارجها توضح بشكل همم
العقوبات اثرت على المواطن الايراني بشكل
اساسي حتى ان الدراسه ايرانيه مهمه جدا
همم تقول بان حركه حلقه القياده في ايران
لم تتاثر همم
بالعقوبات لكن الطب متوسطه في ايران تاثرت
بالعقوبات الاخيره بشكل بشكل ملحوظ لذلك
هذه العقوبات تؤثر على المجتمع الايراني
بصوره اساسيه وهذا وجدنا تداعيات في
الحاله الاقتصاديه همم في ايران ال- همم
القول بان العقوبات حتى وان استهدفت الحرس
الثوري من الممكن ان تؤثر على الحرس
كمؤسسه هذه همم وجهه نظر همم مبالغ فيها
لانه دورات العقوبات السابقه كلها كان
يتعامل معها بشكل اساسي الحرس الثوري
بوصفه لمشغل الاقتصادي الثاني بعد الحكومه
الايرانيه ووصفه على تماس بشكل مباشر في
القضايا المتعلقه بموضوع همم سواء تصدير
النفط او التعامل مع العقوبات وايجاد حلول
لمواجهه هذه همم العقوبات الاطراف
الاوروبيه همم في ظني من وجهه نظري همم
هذه الحساسيه تجاه الحرس الثور او الضغط
همم على الحرس الثوري له ما يتجاوز
الموضوع همم النووي هناك عده مسائل في هذا
الاتجاه اولها ان الاوروبيين يعتقدون ان
من يعيق التوصل الى اتفاق لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي الحرس الثوري بشكل
اساسي لان الحرس الثوري ارسل رسائل متعدده
بانه في بعض القضايا انه لا يقبل بتنازلات
بشانها المساله الاخرى المهمه التي يحاول
الاوروبيين الضغط بشانها تتعلق بالبرنامج
الصاروخ الايراني والتطور التسلح الايراني
بشكل اوسع لان الاوروبيين يرون بان الحرس
هو الذي يقود دفه همم التطور التسلحي في
ايران خاصه البرنامج الصاروخ الايراني وفي
اكثر من مره قال الاوروبيون انه هم يريدون
من ايران ان تتفاوض بشان البرنامج الصاروخ
الايراني والحرس قال ان هذا خط احمر لن
يسمح مسئولي ايراني بالتفاوض بشانها لذلك
هناك مسائل معقده جدا تتجاوز الموضوع
النووي في علاقه او في توجهات الاطراف
الاوروبيه تجاه الحرس الثوري وبالتالي
دكتور عبد الله في هذه الحاله همم يعني من
النقطه التي يمكن ان تبدا من عندها هذه
المفاوضات يعني هل هذه العقوبات همم غير
ذات الاثر على التسلسل القيادي في ايران
يمكن التفاوض بشانها مع انها غير مرتبطه
بالبرنامج النووي الايراني
يعني انا اعتقد يعني بعد ثمان جولات من
المفاوضات وتوقفها لعشره اشهر الان وندخل
في الشهر الحادي عشر
الجميع يريد ان يعود الى التفاوض الجميع
يريد ان يصل الى اتفاق نووي لان البديل هو
ان الشيطان تنسحب من الام بي تي اتفاقيه
الحد من انتشار النووي الموقع عليها عن 68
والتي ترفض اسرائيل التوقيع عليها ايران
تصعد اكثر يمكن تقوم بعمليات عبرعها في
المنطقه ولكن يعني في النهايه اعتقد سيتم
التفاوض حول مخرج الماء مال اللي عنده
الكثير من الافكار الاولويه ايضا ليست
لايران وليست يعني عند اداره الشرق الاوسط
وايران ليس من الاولويه اذا قرانا ناشونال
سكيورتي همم استراتي
استراتيجيه الامن الوطني واستراتيجيه
وزاره الدفاع نرى بان هناك في تخفيض
لاهميه الشرق الاوسط والخليج هناك تركيز
اكبر على كيف نحتوي الصين وكيف نوا روسيا
وهذا الكلام قبل اكرانيا والان مع
اوكرانيا صار التركيز اكثر ولكن يعني
النقطه المهمه في كل ذلك هو اننا نبقى
متفرجين يعني ايران تزود عندها قدرات صارت
تنتج اسلحه تنتج الصواريخ بعيده المدى
ومسيرات تدمر التحتيه وايضا تخصب
اليورانيوم في فرده وفي غيرها من المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه بشكل متسارع وهذا يدفع
اداره وايضا والاوروبيين
للحث اكثر على القيام
بانجاح المفاوضات بتقديم نوعا من
التنازلات الترضيات لايران وحتى ايضا نزع
فتيل التصعيد من اسرائيل وقد يعني لا
استبعد ان يقوم الشهر القادم همم
سنعود الى دكتور عبد الله حينما يتم اصلاح
الخط معه دكتوره فاطمه صمادي
الربط بين الربط بين ال ال
المظاهرات
والعقوبات الخاصه بها وبين البرنامج
النووي الايراني كيف تنظر اليه طيران
حقوق الانسان هو ذريعه سياسيه يتخذها
الغرب للضغط على على ايران ولذلك وجدنا
انه حتى في بيانات التي صدرت عن مجلس
الامن القومي ااه الايراني كان يشير الى
ان هناك دول غربيه همم اضافه الى اطراف
اقليميه في تاجير همم حاله الاحتجاج في
ايران وتعمل بشكل اساسي الى دول اوروبيه
بعينها في الايام الاخيره هناك همم نوع من
ال- ال- مهاجمه الدوري الالماني على همم
هذا الصعيد هو سابقا كان هناك حديث عن دور
البريطانيه هناك دائما همم في ايران هناك
نوع من المحاوله للحديث عن همم توظيف
السياسي للحاله الاحتجاجيه همم في ايران
لكن اذا تابعنا ال- ال- حتى همم
ما يصدر عن المؤسسات الاعلاميه على الحرس
الثوري فهناك اقرار بحاله ازمه في ايران
همم اقرار بحاله الازمه بشكل همم داخلي
همم
يشير الى ان هناك نوع من القراءه المختلفه
عن السابق لما يجري في ايران وعدم الحديث
فقط ان ذلك يتم همم من قبل تاجيج الاطراف
الرجيم
لكن دكتور عبد الله الشرجي همم اظن عاد
الينا مره اخرى دكتور
بالنسبه لهذا الوضع نحن الان في مرحله
سبات لمفاوضات الاحياء المفاوضات الاحياء
اللي اتفاق النووي الايراني هنالك تصريحات
تصعيديه من من الجانبين وعود مره اخرى
للدكتور عبد الله هذا الوضع دكتور عبد
الله كيف تتعامل معه دول المنطقه حاله
الغموض وعدم الوضوح
وهذا وضع يمكن ان يتطور في اي اتجاه يعني
صحيح حضرتك استبعت الخيار العسكري لكن كل
من يتحدث حتى من اساس الغربي لا يستبعدون
ذلك ايضا
اعتقد في عمل عسكري سيكون مزلزل للمنطقه
الاقتصاد العالمي للنفط
للاستقرار الدولي بالاضافه الى الحرب
اوكرانيا التي بلا افق ولتحول باستنزاف
دول الخليج ليس من مصلحتها ان تصطف مع
اسرائيل ضد ايران هي هذه ليست معركتنا دول
الخليج لا تزال تفضل التفاوض والتقارب او
فتح مجالات للتفاوض مع ايران البعد
الاقتصادي ايضا مهم بعد امن الطاقه مهم
اسرائيل لا تعول على دول الخليج باي طريقه
لان تكون طرفا في هذه المواجهه هذه ليست
مواجهتنا يعني اسرائيل تريد ان تتكسب تريد
ان تتكر النووي وتبقى الدوله النوويه
الوحيده في المنطقه
ولذلك ولكن في يعني هناك يجب ان نفهم
تخادم يوجد خطوط حمراء اسرائيل تعلمها
وايران تعلمها ايران لم ترد على اي من
الاختيالات الكبيره التي حدثت للعلماء
النوويين لم ترد على الاعتداءات المتكرره
في نعم في ايران لن تقوم باي عمل فيه
مجازر
يمكن الحفاظ عليه
الظروف للاستئناف من جديد اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت واشكر
ضيفتنا من الدوحه الدكتوره فاطمه الباحثه
الاولى في مركز الجزيره للدراسات
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج نور
الخبر في امان الله
[موسيقى]